The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I like to
discuss with you solution
methods that we use to solve the
finite element equations
in nonlinear static analysis.
In the previous lectures, we
derived this set of equations,
where tK is a tangent
stiffness matrix.
Delta Ui is a nodal point
vector of incremental
displacements corresponding
to iteration i.
t plus delta t R is the
externally applied load vector
corresponding to time
t plus delta t.
And t plus delta t F i minus 1
is equal to the nodal point
force vector corresponding to
the internal elements stresses
at time t plus delta t,
and at the end of
iteration i minus 1.
The displacements are updated
as shown here.
Delta Ui, of course,
is calculated
from this set of equations.
We add delta Ui to the previous
displacements that
corresponded to iteration
t plus delta --
to time t plus delta t and
iteration i minus 1.
It's the end of iteration
i minus 1.
And this right-hand side gives
us the new displacement vector
corresponding to iteration
i, end of iteration i.
Now this is one scheme that it's
used to solve the finite
element equations.
We refer to this as
the mortified
Newton-Raphson method.
However, there are other
schemes as well.
And schemes that are in certain
problems much more effective.
Since it is so important to use
an effective method for
the solution of the finite
element equations because the
costs can otherwise be very
high, we should be familiar
with those other techniques.
And I'd like to share
those now with you.
Therefore, we will look in
this lecture at other
techniques to solve the finite
element equations.
And we need, of course, to
discuss convergence criteria.
It's very important to use
appropriate convergence criteria.
Otherwise, you iterate too long
and/or on the other side,
you may actually stop iterating
before you have
achieved proper convergence.
So let me then go over to my
view graphs and let us start
the discussion here.
The basic set of equations that
we would like to solve
are given here.
Notice R is the vector of
externally applied nodal point
forces at time t plus delta t.
And F is the vector of nodal
point forces corresponding to
the internal element stresses
at time t plus delta t.
Of course, this vector is
unknown, and we want to
iterate somehow to find it and
make sure, of course, that at
the end of that iteration, if we
have the proper vector F, R
is equal to F, or R minus
F is equal to 0.
We assume that the loading is
deformation-independent.
If say, loading is
deformation-dependent, we can
also deal with that situation.
But we will have to add
additional terms to our
iterative scheme.
And I will get back to
that a little later.
Notice that F in the total
Lagrangian formulation the way
we have discussed it earlier is
evaluated by this product
here integrated over the
original volume for a single
element and for the UL
formulation, F is calculated
as shown here.
Here, of course, we integrate
over the current volume, or
the volume that we actually
want to calculate.
Notice in the iteration, of
course, this volume here would
be t plus delta t V i minus 1
as we will discuss just now.
Because in the iteration, we
always update this integral
and that integral with the
iteration counter that we are
having on the right-hand side
of the system of equations.
The methods that we use are
based on the Newton-Raphson
method, which is really used
very abundantly to find roots
of an equation.
A small historical note:
Newton gave a first version
of the method in 1669.
Raphson then generalized and
simplified the method
actually, in 1690.
Both mathematicians used
the same concept.
And both algorithms gave really,
the same results.
But it is very appropriate to
refer to the methods that
we're using as the
Newton-Raphson method because
Raphson really contributed quite
a bit to that method.
So let us now consider a single
Newton-Raphson iteration.
The way you may have actually
encountered it already earlier
in your studies of solution
methods for the roots of an
algebraic equation.
Basically, what you're
doing is this.
You're saying if you have xi
minus 1, you calculate
f at xi minus 1.
You divide this value by the
f prime at xi minus 1.
And then this right-hand side
gives you better value, a
better approximation to the
root of the equation.
Once you have xi, you repeat
the process and
you get xi plus 1.
You keep on repeating the
process until, basically f xi
here is close to 0.
Because then you have a root.
Well, if we use that
Newton-Raphson formula, it is
quite interesting to see how
it has been derived.
We can write for any point xi,
a neighboring point xi minus
1, directly this equation here
by a Taylor series expansion.
And if we neglect the higher
order terms, we get that f of
xi is approximately equal to
this relationship on the
right-hand side.
Well, since f of xi is supposed
to be 0, because we
are looking for a 0 of
the equation, we
set it equal to 0.
And here you see directly
the formula that
I showed you earlier.
So this is a very quick
derivation of the
Newton-Raphson procedure.
Let us look at a mathematical
example to see how the method
works, and to get some insight
into the technique.
Let us choose a very simple
example, not much to do with
finite element analysis.
Let us say that f of x equals
sine x and that our starting
value is equal to 2
for the iteration.
You always have to choose, of
course, a starting value for
the iteration.
Then, in this column you see the
values that are calculated
in the successive iterations.
And we also show
here the error.
It is interesting to observe
that when you are close to the
root, you have quadratic
convergence.
Meaning that the error here,
epsilon becomes an error.
Epsilon squared here.
This is summarized on
this view graph.
Mathematically, if we have that
the error, Ei minus 1, is
given by this equation here.
Of course, there's an
approximate sign here.
Then the error in the
next iteration
will be of this order.
So the convergence is really
very rapid once we are close
to the root.
Here we can see, however,
that if we are not
close to the root--
in other words, if we are too
far from the root, and we pick
a bad value, then we don't
get to the desired
root, which is pi.
But we get a value that
is far away from pi.
It is also root, but certainly
not the root that we are
interested in.
So Newton-Raphson iteration
is not always convergent
directly, converging directly
to the result that we would
like to obtain.
There has to be some care when
we use that iterative scheme.
And in fact, we have to be close
enough just to basically
say what has to happen.
We have to be close enough to
the root in order to have
convergence to the root that
we're looking for.
And ultimately, if we do
converge to that root, we will
get quadratic convergence
to the root.
And that is, of course,
very desirable.
But the starting value is
critical, as you can see here
from this view graph.
Let us look pictorially at
the solution process.
Here we have our
sine function.
And we are looking
for this root.
In iteration 1, we basically set
up a tangent to that sine
function at the starting
value, x0.
And we calculate x1 using this
tangent as another estimate to
the value that we're
interested in.
Now in the iteration 2, we lay
a tangent to the f function.
Which, of course, is sine
x, at the new value
corresponding to x1.
And with this tangent,
we get to this value.
And you can see already
that we got closer
to the desired value.
We were this far away
originally.
Then that far away.
And now we are only
that far away.
Notice our sine function
has this value here.
And certainly, it's not 0 yet.
So we lay another tangent
at that point.
And that's being done on
this view graph here.
Another tangent, and now
we get much closer
to the desired value.
Right here, x3 is already
quite close.
But not close enough as
shown by this value.
It's not yet close enough
to 0, this length here.
And we lay another tangent
to that point now.
And that's shown on this
view graph now.
And we can see with the blue
line being the tangent at this
point, we get x4 very close
to the 0 value that we are
actually interested in.
Certainly on this view graph,
you can't see any difference
anymore between x4 and
the desired value.
So this is basically the process
that we are following
through when we go from
iteration 1 to iteration 2 to
iteration 3 and to
iteration 4.
Beautiful convergence in this
particular example.
And the reason being that x0 is
close enough to the desired
value, the desired root.
Which, itself, of course,
is close to x4.
Four
Well, if however, we were to
take a value that is not close
enough and then we, as I showed
earlier, we do not
converge to the actual root.
And this is shown here.
For example, if we take a
tangent at a point where f of
prime is almost 0, then of
course, this tangent throws us
far away from this root.
And we will converge
to some other root.
Of course, we don't want to use
an exact 0 here because we
have f of x divided
by f prime of x.
So with an exact 0, we could
not [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But a tangent that is close to
0, an f prime value that is
close to 0, would throw us far
away from the desired root.
And that shows some of the
difficulties using--
in fact, almost all iterative
schemes that we may not get
fast enough to our root.
And in fact, we may never get
to the root that we are
looking for.
Well, let us then look at the
Newton-Raphson iteration for
multiple degrees of freedom.
Here we have our R minus
F that we want to
be setting to 0.
Or we want to rather, solve for
the displacements t plus
delta t U, which are the
solution because this t plus
delta t u displacements would
give us this force vector.
And this force vector
equilibrates the R vector.
Meaning f of U, this little
f of U, is equal to 0.
And that, of course, is what
we want to achieve.
Notice that we have here,
of course, now
n degrees of freedom.
Therefore, n equations
to solve.
Previously, we only looked
at one equation.
If we apply the same principle
as before to this little f,
namely we expand f as a Taylor
series about t plus delta t U
i minus 1, then we get
this equation on
the right-hand side.
And of course, on the left-hand
side, we have f of t
plus delta t Ui.
Notice they are higher terms,
which we will neglect just as
we have done earlier for
the single equation.
Because we are looking for
Taylor series expansion about
t plus delta t U i minus 1.
If we neglect this part here,
we obtain directly this
equation here.
0 on the left-hand side, because
once again, we are
looking for the displacements
values for which f is 0.
So therefore, we set this
deliberately equal to 0.
And on the right-hand side, we
have f t plus delta t U i
minus 1 plus partial f with
respect to U times the delta
U. This delta U is unknown,
of course,
that we want to calculate.
And this delta U is nothing
else then the difference
between the U value in iteration
i and the U value in
iteration i minus 1.
Notice that this f is
evaluated at t plus
delta t U i minus 1.
Let us look now at
this equation.
And if we write it a little bit
more out, we find that on
the left-hand side, we have,
of course, a vector of 0's.
On the right-hand side, we
have a vector of f i
components, f1 to fn.
All of which are evaluated at
t plus delta t U i minus 1.
And then we have here a matrix,
which is a square
matrix in which the individual
elements are partials of f i
with respect to Uj.
For example, f1, partial f1
with respect to U1 here.
Partial fn with respect to
U n here, et cetera.
This matrix here will give us
a tangent stiffness matrix.
Notice this matrix is multiplied
by the vector of
incremental nodal point
displacements corresponding to
iteration i.
If we remember that f, the
little f, at t plus delta t U
i minus 1 is equal to R minus
2 plus delta t F i minus 1.
Capital F here, little
f there, remember?
Then, the partial of little f
with respect to U at t plus
delta t U i minus 1 is given
via this equation.
Now, please recognize that
partial of R with respect to U
is equal to 0 if the loads are
deformation-independent.
Of course, if the loads depend
on the deformations, in other
words, if the loads depend on
the U displacements, then this
would not be 0, and we would
have to actually put a term in
here, carry that term along
in the solution of
the nonlinear equations.
But for the moment,
we neglect this.
We assume that the loads are
deformation-independent.
And then, this term
is equal to 0.
This here is now giving us the
tangent stiffness matrix.
And it is written down here.
The tangent stiffness matrix
is nothing else than the
partials of capital F with
respect to the U's, to the
displacements.
The final result then is given
on this view graph.
We substitute all the
information that I shared with
you into the Taylor series
expansion around t plus delta
t U i minus 1.
We get directly this
equation here.
Notice tangent stiffness matrix
corresponding to time t
plus delta t and iteration
i minus 1.
Delta U i corresponding to
iteration i we have to be very
clear about this, that this is
an increment in displacement
from time t plus delta t
iteration i minus 1 to
iteration i.
And of course, the nodal
point force vector.
Externally applied nodal point
forces go in here.
And this is the nodal point
force vector corresponding to
the internal element stresses at
time t plus delta t and at
the end of iteration
i minus 1.
Evaluated differently in the
total Lagrangian formulation
from the way we're evaluating
it in the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
We talked about this vector
abundantly in
the previous lectures.
We talked about this vector,
of course, also in the
previous lectures.
We had in the previous lectures
here at tK, a
constant tangent stiffness
matrix, which was set up at
the beginning of this whole
interactive process, and was
never updated.
Well, here we now update
that stiffness matrix.
And I think if you look through
the information that I
just discussed with you,
you recognize why
we're updating it.
We are doing so because we are
always starting with the new
Taylor series expansion about
the point i minus 1.
This set of equations if of
course solved for delta Ui.
We add delta Ui to what we
had already in terms of
displacements to get our new
estimate for the nodal point
displacements.
It is important to realize that
the K matrix, which we
are using in the solution
process, is symmetric.
Because first of all, we use
symmetric stress and strain
measures in our governing
equation.
Remember that when we apply the
principle of virtual work,
we use Cauchy stresses
and infinitesimally
small virtual strains.
Now notice that both of these
tenses are symmetric tenses.
Of course, these are the tenses
we're using in the UL,
in the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation, we use the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress in
Green-Lagrange strain.
Both of these measures are
again, symmetric measures.
Both tenses are symmetric
tenses.
If we had introduced for a
formulation non-symmetric
tenses, for example a
non-symmetric stress tenser,
and of course, an energy
conjugate non-symmetric strain
tenser, we would have obtained
a non-symmetric K matrix,
which would be much more
difficult to deal with.
Much less cost effective in
the solution process.
Also, please recognize that
we interpolated the real
displacements and the virtual
displacements with exactly the
same functions.
Whereas this point here is a
continuum mechanics point,
this is really a finite
element point.
If we had used different
interpolation functions for
the real displacements, then for
the virtual displacements,
or vice-versa, then we would
have not necessarily obtained
a symmetric K matrix.
Of course, the most natural
procedure is to use the same
kind of interpolation functions
for the virtual
displacements as we used for
the real displacements, and
that's what we did.
Finally, we also assumed
that the loading was
deformation-independent.
If we have deformation-dependent
loading,
then if you go more back to the
earlier view graph, then
of course, this right-hand
side vector R here would
depend on the displacements.
And there are basically two
different approaches
that one can take.
In the first approach, one
simply updates this vector
with the iteration, or with
taking into account the
current or last calculated
volume and surface areas for
the elements.
So we would simply put here
an i minus 1 up there.
The left-hand side matrix,
we leave unchanged.
And if that converges fast,
certainly it's a very
effective approach to use.
We use that approach
abundantly.
However, another approach
is to actually take the
differentiation of R with
respect to the U's, the way we
have been looking at it earlier
on an earlier view
graph, and then you get some
components that you
add to the K matrix.
And that K matrix may then
out to be non-symmetric.
However, if the loading is
deformation-independent, then
the differentiation of R with
respect to the displacements U
is equal to 0, and there's
no component from that
differentiation coming
into the K matrix.
And our K, of course, provided
these are also
satisfied, is symmetric.
The iterative scheme that we
just discussed is referred to
as the full Newton-Raphson
method.
Full because we are setting
up a new K matrix at the
beginning of each iteration.
The full Newton-Raphson method
shows mathematically quadratic
convergence the way we discussed
it a bit earlier in
the lecture.
And that, of course, is always
the case provided you are
close enough to the root.
This quadratic convergence only
holds provided you are
close enough to the root when
you solve your equations.
In finite element analysis, it
is also important to recognize
that a number of requirements
must be fulfilled.
For example, in elasto-plastic
analysis, the stresses and
strains must be properly--
plastic strains must be
properly updated.
And similarly, the rotations
in a shell analysis must be
properly updated.
So it is not necessarily the
case that you automatically
get quadratic convergence when
you do finite element
announces with a full
Newton-Raphson method.
It is very important to also,
on the level of updating the
stresses and the rotations,
really do things properly in
quotes in order to obtain the
full quadratic convergence of
the Newton-Raphson method.
We can depict the iteration
process in
two equivalent ways.
The first way is shown
here, the left.
And it's really the way we've
been discussing just now the
solution of f equals R minus
capital F. Where we want to
solve for the root, the
0 of this equation.
Notice here we have in red
the little f depicted.
Notice that at this point here,
we have t plus delta t
capital F i minus 1.
And t plus delta t
R is this value.
Now, as we get closer to the
root, which is of course, the
point where the red curve
crosses this U-axis, as we get
closer to the root, this capital
F will get closer and
closer to the R. And that is,
of course, when the little f
is equal to 0.
That's all we are
showing here.
Notice that we are setting up
a slope f prime at the point
corresponding to the i minus
first iteration.
And that slope brings us into
this point, which will be the
next point for--
or the next starting point
for the next iteration.
I should say, the point
of starting
with the next iteration.
Now, this is one way
of looking at
the iterative process.
We can also look at
it as shown here.
Notice we have here the R
plotted now horizontally.
The displacement vertically.
Notice the R at a particular
time t plus delta t is shown
by this dashed line.
And we really want to find this
particular point here and
the corresponding U displacement
of course.
At this point, the little f is
0 and the corresponding U
displacement is down here.
Notice that at the iteration
i minus 1, it's the end of
iteration i minus 1, we have
obtained this point here.
The U displacement corresponding
to that point is
obtained by projecting down
on the displacement axes.
And this slope here, the blue
line, gives us a tangent
stiffness matrix slope.
These are two equivalent ways.
This is here more like a force
deflection curve, and we will
use this representation
now abundantly.
But keep in mind, it's really
the same thing if you look at
it closely.
Well, modifications
to the iterative
scheme are the following.
If we leave the stiffness matrix
constant throughout a
complete solution process--
in other words, tau is
equal to 0 here.
It's never updated.
We talk about the initial
stress method.
If tau is equal to t, where t,
of course, corresponds to a
particular solution step and
meaning that the K matrix is
constant, but it is updated
as the beginning
of a solution step.
Then we talk about the modified
Newton method.
Modified Newton-Raphson
method.
Or, we may also find it
effective to update the K
matrix only at particular
solution steps, at certain
times only.
We note that the initial stress
method and the modified
Newton methods are, of course,
much less expensive than the
full Newton method per
iteration, however.
We should add that many more
iterations are necessary to
achieve the same accuracy if we
don't set up a new K matrix
in every iteration.
The initial stress method and
modified Newton iteration
technique do not exhibit
quadratic convergence because
to obtain quadratic convergence,
you need to set
up a new K matrix in
each iteration.
And of course, you have to be
close enough to the root, to
the solution that you're
looking for.
Let us now look at
a simple example.
An example where we have just
one degree of freedom.
And where we deal with
two load steps.
Here we show the force
applied to the
problem, or to the structure.
In the first load step,
we apply 1R.
And then in the second
load step, 2R.
Notice horizontally here, I'm
plotting displacements.
And the force displacement
curve is
shown by the red line.
Now, to obtain the solution for
this displacement, U1, and
that displacement U2, we, as
we discussed, set up a K
matrix, which corresponds
to the slope, a
slope on the red curve.
And we iterate towards
the sought solutions.
Here, we have the iterative
process using the initial
stress method.
In other words, where tau is
equal to 0 in our governing
finite element equations.
This means that we are setting
up a K matrix initially, and
that K matrix is depicted here
by the slope, the blue slope
that you're seeing.
Now with this slope and this
load applied, we get the
displacement shown down here.
Notice the left superscript
means load step 1.
The right superscript means
solution after iteration 1.
And this is the solution
obtained from this triangle.
Notice there's a blue line up
there, going up there, and
where that blue line crosses the
dashed line, we pick up a
vertical fine, black line.
And that vertical black line
cuts through the displacement
axes at this particular value.
So this is the solution of
our first iteration.
Now, having calculated this
displacement value, we go up
vertically and get to the
red line, the red curve.
And that red curve corresponds,
of course, to the
internal forces.
To the internal force I should
say, corresponding to this
displacement.
There's a red dot right
on that red curve.
And at that red dot now, we've
set up a K matrix again.
Now notice, in the initial
stress method, we keep the K
matrix constant.
This means that the slope here
of this blue line that goes
through this red point is the
same as the slope that we had
earlier right here.
With that slope and the out of
balance load-- and let's look
now very closely here--
that corresponds to the distance
between this red
point and that dashed line with
this out of balance load
and this blue slope, we get an
increment in displacement
shown right here.
And that increment in
displacement added to the
previous displacement gives
us this value down here.
And in fact, this value is
very close to the correct
solution, the exact solution,
which is the solution
corresponding to the dashed
vertical line here.
Notice that the dashed vertical
line is the exact
solution to that dashed
horizontal line.
And our vertical black line,
which we are calculating, is
virtually on that dashed
black line.
So we can accept now,
convergence.
Let's now go into the
next load step.
In the next load step,
we want to, again,
deal with a K matrix.
And in the initial stress
method, we use the same K
matrix throughout
the solution.
Meaning that the slope now,
which we are laying onto the
red curve, that slope being this
blue line, is the same
slope that we used before in
the first two iterations.
With this slope and the out of
balance load corresponding to
the distance between this
horizontal line, the dashed
horizontal line, and that dashed
horizontal line because
we conversed in the
first load step.
With that out of balance load,
we get an incremental
displacement shown from
here to there.
And that incremental
displacement then, added to
the previous displacement,
gives us this value in
displacement.
Notice time t plus delta t or
load step t plus delta t,
which is here.
Load step 2 and iteration
1, end of iteration 1.
This is now our current
displacement.
With this current displacement,
once again,
which comes from this triangle
here, with this current
displacement, we go vertically
up and get to that red point,
which lies on the force
displacement curve--
internal force displacement
curve more accurately.
And now we have this red point,
and we set up, or we
use now, again, a K matrix.
Of course, in the initial
stress method we use the
constant K matrix.
So this slope is the
same as that slope.
And now watch closely.
From this triangle here, which
corresponds to this out of
balance load, which is
the same as that
out of balance load.
Out of balance load obtained
by putting here
a horizontal line.
Notice and the difference
between the dashed line up
there and the horizontal line
given by my pointer is the out
of balance load.
Which of course, is the same as
the distance between this
red point and that
dashed line.
This out of balance load with
this slope gives us another
increment in displacement,
which brings us
to this value here.
We repeat that process and
iteratively, we get closer and
closer to the correct solution,
the exact solution,
which is the dashed vertical
line here for the
displacement.
Because at that dashed vertical
line, we are getting
to that red curve.
Now, this is the initial
stress method.
And once again, the point here
is that we kept the same K
matrix throughout the
solution process.
Surely, if you now were to look
at this iterative scheme
to obtain a faster solution,
you would want to
set up a new K matrix.
In other words, once you have
this displacement value
calculated, you want to update
the slope corresponding to the
slope of the red curve.
And if you do so--
in other words, you update this
blue slope corresponding
to the red dots that you
have obtained in
your iterative scheme.
These red dots, of course,
being different from what
you're seeing here now.
Then you would have the full
Newton-Raphson method.
If you only update the K matrix
or the blue tangent
that we are seeing here whenever
you have converged to
an equilibrium point.
Meaning when you have converged
corresponding for
the first load step in
this particular case.
If you only update the stiffness
matrix once you have
converged to this load--
for this load step, then you
would have the modified
Newton-Raphson method.
I think if you look at this
picture with these
possibilities, you will realize
that surely, the full
Newton-Raphson method with
updating the slope after each
iteration will converge
fastest.
And the modified Newton-Raphson
method will
converge a little slower than
the full Newton-Raphson
method, but still faster than
the initial stress method.
Well, this then brings us to the
end of the discussion of
this example.
I like to now introduce you to
another scheme that can be
very important when we solve
nonlinear equations, finite
element equations.
And that scheme is the scheme
of line searches.
The basic equations that we are
looking at that we want to
solve are once more
depicted here.
Tangent stiffness matrix,
incremental displacement
vector, externally applied
loads, nodal point forces
corresponding to the internal
element stresses at time t
plus delta t, and at the end
of iteration i minus 1,
beginning of iteration
i, of course.
Notice I don't have an i on
here, I just want to denote
this for the moment as an
incremental nodal point
displacement vector, which
carries, however, a bar.
Let us consider forming Fi using
this equation where beta
is an unknown.
We want to choose beta
now judiciously.
We want to choose beta such
that, in some sense, R minus
Fi is small.
And we have to, of course, look
at the mechanism that we
use to make R minus F
small in some sense.
Well, as a side note, we
recognize that when this
equation here is 0 for all
possible U's, then clearly
this must be 0.
In other words, if we were to
say to ourselves, let's make
this equation 0 for
all possible U's.
Then really, we would have
solved this equal to 0.
The reason, of course, for it
is that we could choose here
for U a vector, which carries
0's everywhere except a 1 in
one location.
And if that is a particular
row, then corresponding to
that row, surely this vector
here, this R minus F
corresponding to that row
must be equal to 0.
So if we were simply to use here
the identity matrix, or
if we were to construct the
identity matrix by allowing n
U's that are linearly
independent, of course,
because they all make up such
vector but with a 1 in a
different location.
As a matter of fact, we want to
use U1 with a 1 here, 0's
everywhere.
U2, 1 here, 0 here, everywhere
else 0, and so on.
To construct an identity
matrix here.
Then with that identity matrix,
clearly R minus F
would be 0 everywhere.
Of course, that is not a
viable scheme really.
But what we want to do is to
choose a particular vector
here so as to make R minus
F still 0 in some sense.
And the vector that is quite
effectively chosen is the
vector that we obtain from the
solution of K delta U bar
equals R minus F.
If we use that vector here,
basically projecting the R,
capital R, minus F
onto that vector.
And we look for this to be 0.
Then we have so to say, searched
in the direction of
delta U bar and made delta U
bar transposed times this
vector here equal to 0.
How does this scheme work?
Well, we add beta times delta U
bar to the value that we had
already from the previous
iteration.
And we search along beta such
that this top here is much
smaller than the bottom.
In other words, STOL shall be
a convergence tolerance.
Notice the way it works.
We choose a value of beta.
With beta known, we add this
quantity to this one.
We get a value here.
We take this value, calculate
Fi corresponding to that
value, see whether
the convergence
tolerance is satisfied.
If not, we have to choose
a new beta.
And like that, we choose new
betas until we have satisfied
this convergence tolerance.
That's what we call
line search.
We are searching along the
line given by delta U bar
until this is satisfied.
It's a very important scheme,
and this scheme can be
combined with modified Newton
iteration, with the initial
stress method, and with
full Newton iteration.
And it adds a lot to the
stability of the solution, of
the overall solution or the
nonlinear equations.
We will find, or discuss
applications just now.
But at this point, we need to
stop for a minute because we
need to go onto a new tape.
Finally, I would like to discuss
with you a method that
we also find to be very
effective in nonlinear finite
element computations.
Namely, the BFGS method.
BFGS stands for Broyden-Fletcher
-Goldfarb-Shanno.
And in this method, we
proceed as follows.
We calculate or define
a delta i as shown
here in this equation.
And we define a gamma i as
shown in this equation.
We want to calculate the
coefficient matrix such that
this equation is
here satisfied.
In other words, given delta i
and gamma i, we want to use
the coefficient matrix that
satisfies this equation.
And that's basically what's
being done in the BFGS scheme.
Pictorially then, we can show
for a single degree of freedom
system, say the F plotted
along this axis.
The U displacements plotted
Notice here in green
we show delta i.
And we show here in
green gamma i.
And notice that the matrix
that we want to use is
indicated by this blue slope.
Which is, in other words, given
by delta i and gamma i.
Well, the BFGS method is an
iterative algorithm, which
produces successive
approximations to efficient
stiffness matrix.
Actually, we actually work
with the inverse of that
stiffness matrix as I will
elaborate upon just now.
It's really a compromise
between the full Newton
iteration method and
the modified
Newton iteration method.
It shows very excellent
convergence characteristics in
the solution of many
types of problems.
Let's look at the individual
steps that we use when we
apply the BFGS method.
We, first of all, calculate
the direction of the
displacement increment.
Here we have delta U bar i is
equal to K inverse, the
inverse of the K matrix,
corresponding to
iteration i minus 1.
And here we have the out
of balance load vector.
Notice once again we do not
calculate actually an inverse
of a matrix.
We calculate the LDL transpose
factorization of a matrix, and
then we, as I will just now
show, update that inverse in
the BFGS iteration by specific
matrices of rank 2.
We get to that just now.
Well, having calculated this
delta U bar i, we use that
delta U bar i in the line search
to obtain a better
displacement vector, a
displacement vector
corresponding to iteration i.
A better value then just adding
the delta U bar i to it
by adjusting beta.
In other words, we choose beta
in such way as to satisfy this
equation here.
This is, of course, the equation
that we are now
familiar with as being equation
that shows that
convergence has been reached
in a line search.
Having now calculated the t
plus delta t Ui and the
corresponding t plus delta t Fi,
we can calculate the delta
i and gamma i.
And therefore, apply
the BFGS method.
And that's now step three,
calculation of
the new secant matrix.
K inverse of iteration i is
equal to Ai transposed k
inverse of iteration
i minus 1 times Ai.
This A matrix is obtained
as shown here.
v wi transposed.
The vi and wi's are given as a
function of the delta i, gamma
i, and K i minus 1 value.
You should look at the textbook
to see the details of
actually evaluating
the vi and wi.
But once you have vi, wi, you
can calculate A. And clearly,
by this equation then, you get
a new stiffness matrix.
It is important to note that in
this iterative scheme, only
vector products are needed
to obtain vi and wi.
And it's also then important
to note that only vector
products are used to calculate
delta U bar i.
If this would not be the case,
particularly here.
Then of course, the
iterative scheme
would be very expensive.
Let me show you a bit of the
details why we only need to
use vector products to
get the solution.
Here, we have one typical
step of the iteration.
Notice on the left-hand side,
we have delta U bar i.
The value of displacement
increment
that we want to calculate.
On the right-hand side, we
have i plus wi minus 1 vi
minus 1 transposed.
In other words, the Ai
And we would have such matrices
going on here until
we are coming to the A1
transposed matrix.
Then we have the inverse
of a stiffness matrix.
Here, corresponding
to time tau.
And then we have the Ai matrices
as shown here.
Now, notice that this total
amount then is multiplied by
the R minus F i minus 1, the
out of balance load vector.
Let's now go through the
computations that are required
to get delta U bar i.
Here we have delta R. This delta
R, the out of balance
load vector, which I
just call delta R,
multiplies this matrix.
But if you look at this
multiplication, we find that
this delta R times w i minus 1
transposed is simply a number.
So it's one vector
multiplication
that gives us a number.
This number multiplied by
v i minus 1 is just the
multiplication of a number
times a vector.
It's very simple.
And notice, of course, this
delta R i minus 1 is also
multiplying the identity
matrix.
So in this step here, we have
really nothing else then a
vector multiplication.
The only vector multiplication
that, in fact, is there, is
this value, this vector here,
times that vector there,
transposed.
That gives us a number.
This number times a vector
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
operation.
And of course, this one here
times the i matrix is just
this vector by itself.
So in this step, what
we obtain is
simply another vector.
We take this vector and
repeat the process.
And since the repetition is
just what we discussed
already, we find that we only
need vector multiplications to
roll up all of these
multiplications up to here.
Then we have a vector multiplied
by K inverse.
Well, that involves only vector
multiplications again,
because we have already
the LDL transposed
factorization of tau k.
These vector multiplications
result again, in a vector.
And that vector multiplied by
these matrices here in the
same way as we have proceeded
here, means again, only vector
multiplications.
So this very important step
here only requires vector
multiplications.
And that makes this whole
process really efficient.
In summary then, we have the
following solution procedures
that we feel are
very effective.
The mortified Newton-Raphson
iteration with line searches.
Here we have the basic modified
Newton iteration equation.
And here we have the line
search equation.
We, of course, after each such
solution, evaluate an
efficient beta.
A beta that makes U--
t plus delta U i a good vector
when measured on the line
search criteria the way
I discussed it.
And these two equations then,
summarize really the modified
Newton iteration with
the line search.
The BFGS method is another
effective scheme.
We use the BFGS method always
with line searches.
And then, as a third option,
the full Newton-Raphson
iteration with or without
line searches.
The full Newton-Raphson
iteration with line searches
is, of course, most powerful.
But it is also most expensive
per iteration.
We should point out that these
techniques that I discussed so
far cannot be applied for
post-buckling analysis.
We will consider the solution of
the response after buckling
has been occurring, after the
item load level has been
reached in a forthcoming
lecture.
The next view graphs summarize
these schemes: the modified
Newton-Raphson, the BFGS
method, and the full
Newton-Raphson method.
And I'd like to just very
quickly go through the whole
solution process for each
of these methods.
In the modified Newton iteration
technique, we
initialize our displacements
corresponding to the beginning
of the first iteration, the end
of the 0 iteration as tU.
And similarly, we initialize our
force vector corresponding
to the internal element
stresses.
We set i is equal to 1, the
iteration counter equal to 1.
We calculate a K matrix at the
beginning of the load step,
and we keep that K
matrix constant.
We then go into this step here
where we calculate the out of
balance loads.
Calculate a new displacement
vector.
And in this box here, we
measure whether we have
converged already.
Of course, this convergence
would only be measured after
we have gone say, at
least twice through
the iteration process.
Or rather, we have calculated
this increment in displacement
vector twice.
Because at the beginning
corresponding to i equal to 1,
we have now this fairly large
out of balance load.
We have just incremented
the load vector.
Therefore, this right inside
should be non-zero.
And we would get an increment
in displacements.
And to measure how large that
increment in displacement is,
we really want to go through
this whole cycle at
least one more time.
We then, having calculated this
incremental displacement
vector with the bar on there,
we perform a line search the
way we discussed it to update
our displacements
corresponding to the
iteration i.
Of course, we only have come so
far once through it, so i
is equal to 1 still.
And this gives us the accepted
value of displacements
corresponding to the
first iteration.
We now increment our iteration
counter, and go in to the
second iteration.
Notice now in the second
iteration, we have R minus t
plus delta t F1 here.
We calculate delta U bar 2.
And now we would certainly
measure convergence.
And I will just now talk about
how we measure convergence.
If we have not converged yet,
we keep on cycling through
here until we do actually
get convergence.
The distinguishing feature of
the modified Newton iteration
is that we are having
a constant K matrix.
That we do not update
the K matrix is this
iterative loop here.
It remains constant.
Remember in the initial stress
technique, initial stress
method, we would not even update
the K matrix ever after
the first time it has
been calculated.
But in the modified Newton
iteration, we update it at the
beginning of each load step.
In the BFGS method, we
proceed as follows.
We initial, again, our
displacements and our nodal
point force vector corresponding
to the internal
element stresses.
We calculate tK.
We calculate our incremental
displacement vector with the
bar on top.
We measure convergence if i
is greater or equal to.
There's no point as I just
mentioned, measuring
convergence when you go first
time through here.
And we perform then the line
search having calculated our
actual incremental in nodal
point displacement that we
want to add to the previous
nodal point displacements to
get to this displacement
vector.
We, of course, also have
this force vector.
We now can update our inverse
matrix, our inverse secret
matrix the way we
discussed it.
And we increment our counter.
And we keep on cycling through
here until we find in this box
that we have converged.
In the full Newton iteration
with line searches, we once
again, initialize our
displacement vector, our force
vector, our iteration counter.
We now calculate a new K matrix
corresponding to the
last conditions on displacements
and internal
forces, of course.
We enter here to calculate our
incremental displacement
vector with the K matrix that
was just evaluated.
And we measure convergence
once again only when i is
greater equal to.
We perform a line search to
determine beta in here.
We therefore, update our
displacement vector to the
displacements that now
correspond to the end of
iteration i.
We update our iteration
counter.
Or rather, increase our
iteration counter.
And we are calculating a new
stiffness matrix corresponding
to the last calculated
displacement.
This is, of course, a
distinguishing feature of the
full Newton-Raphson method that
we are calculating a new
K matrix at the beginning
of each iteration.
Well, these view graphs then,
summarize the full process of
iteration for the modified
Newton, the BFGS, and the full
Newton method.
Notice that I have included the
line search as the option.
If you don't have line
searching, of course, it would
simply mean that you set beta
equal to 1, and skip that
particular step of
line searching.
But in many cases, line
searching is quite important.
And certainly, can
be necessary in
some types of problems.
Let us now look at what happens
in this box here.
How do we measure convergence?
In each of these iterative
schemes, we had such a box.
And I like to look now more
closely at how we measure
convergence.
The measure of convergence
should, of course, tell us,
how well do we satisfy
equilibrium?
And there are basically three
items that can be used.
Namely energy, force, or moment,
displacement, and
rotation, of course,
correspondingly as well.
But these are the items that one
can work with to measure
convergence.
If you use an energy convergence
criteria, and we
are very fond of this one.
You might want to use this
equation here delta U bar i
transposed times the out of
balance load divided by delta
U bar 1 transposed times t
plus delta t R minus tF.
Now notice, this is the
increment in nodal point
forces, or the out of
balance load, at the
beginning of the load step.
So this here is an energy
corresponding to the beginning
of the load step.
And we are comparing here
a similar quantity, but
corresponding to the
current load.
Corresponding to the
current iteration.
And if this quotient here is
very small measured on that
convergence tolerance, then
we say we have converged.
An important point is that in
this convergence measure, we
enter with displacements and
with out of balance loads.
Both enter in this convergence
measure.
And please realize also that
if the loads don't increase
from time t to t plus delta t,
meaning that this here is
equal to 0--
0 vector.
Then, of course, we
get 0 down here.
And we could not apply this
convergence criteria
indirectly.
Therefore, we would do is
instead of 0 here, a
reasonable small number in
the computer program.
Also note that we apply
this test here
prior to line searching.
In line searching, after line
searching of course, this top
part here is small.
And we, therefore, do not want
to apply this scheme here or
this convergence measure
after line searching.
We should do it before
line searching.
To measure convergence on
forces, we can use this
equation here.
Notice here we have the
out of balance loads.
We take the Euclidean norm on
the out of balance loads, and
we compare that with
RNORM, input by the
user, by the analyst.
It is interesting, important to
note that we introduce here
only the components
corresponding to the
translational degrees
of freedom.
And here, of course, this
RNORM is also a force
corresponding, so to say, to a
translational degree of freedom.
If we have also rotational
degrees of freedom, then we
would take instead
of RNORM, RMNORM.
And we would extract from these
vectors, the components
corresponding to the rotational
degrees of freedom only.
The point is that we want to
have the same units up
here as down here.
Forces, forces, moments,
moments.
And we don't want to mix
components from these
quantities.
Of course, RMNORM and RNORM must
be chosen by the analyst.
The are input to the analysis as
defined in the input to the
computer program.
Typically, RTOL is 0.01.
RNORM is simply the maximum
of the NORM of the
loads that are applied.
Notice this Euclidean norm is
evaluated as shown down here
for a vector a.
The symbolism, two bars each
side with a 2 means nothing
else then taking the squares of
all the components of the
vector, adding those
squares up.
And then, taking the square
root out of that addition.
On displacements, we can also
measure convergence.
And here is the equation
that can be used.
The Euclidean norm on
the incremental
displacement vector.
And that is compared
with DNORM.
Again, DNORM.
Notice that this here is again,
input by the analyst to
the computer program.
It is part of the input that is
provided for the analysis.
And it's a reference
displacement.
Notice then, of course, we
should only include here the
displacements, translational
displacements in other words.
If we have also, rotational
degrees of freedom.
Then we would here include only
the rotational degrees of
freedom components and
use here DMNORM.
This way again, we compare one
quantity with certain units
with a quantity that
has the same units.
Once for translations and
once for rotations.
And so when we have rotational
degrees of freedom in the
analysis, we this way make
sure really, that the
incremental displacements and
incremental rotations are
small at convergence.
This then completes what I
wanted to share with you in
this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.